porn white swan a pawn yeah wow  incredible gary i think he attacked one  move too many and now he's just got to  pawn not just that the queens are off  prague is almost safe now he's almost  home  that was so quick that was so quick  blink and you miss it it was like the  speed they moved those tactics  incredible  and uh while he's a pawn up in an ending  now this must surely be uh the end um  and it's it's a very good pawn as well  look at this white a pawn this white a  pawn is running up the board and gary  leans back he knows this one it's almost  over and he's given up  takes it wow  16 year old pragmatanda is ready for the  final in chessable masters knocking out  anish giri in an extremely exciting  semi-final match  winning  both of the blitz games ah the last one  was agreed to draw the same as a win  there for prague and look at anish ah  this was not how he pictured  this match to go at the start of the day